je vais vous
les d'un thème universel qu'on appelle
le changement thèmes qui touchent toute
personne dans sa vie au moins une fois
voire plusieurs fois et pour moi ça a
commencé avec ça je vous ai scanner un
électroencéphalogramme pendant toute mon
enfance
ah oui je les scanne et ça m'a pris un
petit peu de temps pendant toute mon
enfance cette maladie qui s'appelle
l'épilepsie m'a accompagné cette maladie
a eu tout de même une vertu la vertu ça
a été de développer mon monde intérieur
j'ai énormément vécu intérieurement du
fait de l'exclusion dès que un enfant à
une différence il est souvent exclues
mis de côté par le moins à l'école par
contre ce point positif ce côté
imagination j'ai pu développer au
travers du temps a été très bénéfique
pour moi alors on peut le voir il ya des
hauts il ya des bas c'est comme la vie
si c'était plat je serais pas devant
vous en faites donc tant mieux qu'ils
aient des hauts et des bas j'aime cette
image qui résume finalement le parcours
d'une vie de tout un chacun
voyageons un petit peu et partons sur un
autre hémisphère en nouvelle angleterre
à sydney une jolie carte postale
j'ai vécu à sydney j'ai travaillé là bas
j'ai fait des choses qui m'ont apporté
beaucoup dans ma vie mais avec tout ça
avec le soleil la mer
l'opéra house derrière moi je n'étais
pas heureux pourquoi je n'étais pas
heureux tout était parfait je
travaillais pour une grande
multinationale
j'avais un statut social qui brillait
mais haut dans mon for intérieur il y
avait quelque chose
une petite voix
qui me disait que il me manquait quelque
chose
si j'ai convoqué se souvenir c'est car
dans la vie vous avez beau être dans le
plus bel endroit du monde
si vous n'êtes pas bien intérieurement
rien et bien et le bonheur n'est pas
accessible
difficile d'être heureux c'est pour être
la question d'une vie comment être
heureux
j'aimerais aujourd'hui vous fait
réfléchir sur cette idée du bonheur est
sur cette dynamique du changement ayant
été épileptique petit j'ai développé une
capacité à vouloir tout contrôler alors
grosse vertueux j'ai pu accéder à des
choses exceptionnelles créer des
sociétés voyage et entreprendre mais par
contre la crise d'épilepsie en elle même
a provoqué chez moi une peur cette peur
avec plus que la crise elle-même la peur
d'avoir une crise a créé chez moi une
sorte de comportement basé sur le
contrôle voire lesur contrôle et pendant
des années j'ai voulu tout contrôler or
tout contrôler n'existe pas c'est un
mythe
on ne peut pas par définition tout
contrôler et je suis arrivé comme cet
homme beau milieu d'un parking seul
j'ai vécu un ko personnel professionnel
intime et une dépression très importante
qui à un moment de ma vie m'a fait poser
des questions j'aime cette phrase qui
dit du cas où naissent les étoiles dans
cette période chaotique de ma vie j'ai
pu me pencher sur ce qui était important
pour moi réfléchir à ce qui faisait sens
pour moi j'ai pris le temps j'en ai
parlé à des gens bienveillants autour de
moi et j'ai décidé de devenir coach en
développement personnel puis d'écrire
des livres comme je le fais aujourd'hui
notre éducation attendant sunu à nous
formater pourquoi j'ai convoqué se
souvenir de l'épilepsie sait car souvent
entre 0 et 10 ans on le sait tout se
joue
on crée des habitudes des réflexes des
comportements que l'on répète et qui ne
sont pas forcément les bons nous n'avons
pas souvent cette lucidité pour savoir
si c'est la bonne direction
une clé possible pour sortir du chaos et
d'écouter notre enfant intérieur en
écoutant notre enfant intérieur on
revient à l'essentiel
alors comment faire pour écouter notre
enfant intérieur
prenez le temps de vous installer
confortablement de rentrer à l'intérieur
de vous et de visualiser ce qui est
important pour vous lorsque vous étiez
enfant
qu'est-ce qui vous animait quels étaient
les personnes que vous admiriez
qu'est-ce que vous écoutiez comme
musique qu'à l'enfant étiez vous je
regrette qu' en france on n'ait pas la
possibilité lorsqu'on est petit de nous
dire pourquoi on est bon pourquoi on est
doué qu'est ce qui fait notre différence
différenciateur ce serait pas génial de
savoir d'emblée là où on est le plus
fort le plus doué là où nos aptitudes
peuvent briller les cours d'éducation
civique sont utiles mais les cours de
développement personnel pour les enfants
pourquoi pas on a tous une structure de
personnalités cette structure de
personnalités secret entre 0 et 10 ans
pourquoi ne pas le savoir tout de suite
en le sachant tout de suite on pourrait
peut-être prendre les meilleures
décisions
aller vers des meilleurs direction et
éviter de choisir des études qui ne nous
plaisent pas les études qui sont
uniquement choisi pour faire plaisir à
notre père ou en haute mer à notre oncle
est pas à nous pourquoi attendre 25 ans
40 ans 50 ans pour apprendre cette
nouvelle je vous invite à explorer cette
enfant intérieur qui est en vous
cet enfant intérieur qui parle qui peut
s'exprimer
si vous lui donnez la chance de revivre
cette pureté de l'enfance est capital
j'ai vécu à l'international et j'avais
mon petit garçon qui était scolarisé
dans différentes écoles à singapour
et en australie et il est vrai que quand
j'allais le chercher à l'école les profs
me disait toujours il y sort good
alors moi en bon français je me disais
bon ok c'est vrai qu'il est fort mais
non il a juste fait un dessin quoi c'est
pas mais le truc c'est que à force
d'antan 10e good
ils ont réussi à développer chez moi un
réflexe un comportement positif qui fait
qu'à la maison je lui disais toujours
ces extras top
j'avais conditionné mon comportement en
mode positif alors ce que j'adore dans
cette mentalité anglo saxon c'est cette
capacité à s'émerveiller de choses
toutefois simple mais à s'émerveiller
si on pouvait garder une chose positive
de l'univers anglo saxons c'est
certainement en tout cas selon moi cette
chose-là cette chose-là qui fait que
tout est possible que l'échec n'est
qu'un passage n'est qu'une étape qui va
vous mener vers autre chose qui va vous
permettre de construire quelque chose de
plus grand l'éducation en france c'est
souvent ce que j'ai entendu tu as quatre
défauts et une qualité
allez vas-y va s en sortir avec ça dans
la vie importe c'est sur les épaules à
cinq ans six ans comment gérer ça
comment gérer heureusement tous les
professeurs d'école ne sont pas comme ça
il ya des gens d'excellents pédagogue
mais malheureusement on retrouve souvent
le verre à moitié vide plutôt que le
verre à moitié plein c'est quand même
une grande tendance
on vit dans un pays exceptionnel
on a des ressources incroyables une
culture que le monde nous envie
comment se fait-il qu'en france on se
voit les champions des antidépresseurs
comment se fait-il en france qu'en
soient les champions des suicides
pour ce convoyage et vous le savez
lorsqu'on voyage lorsqu'on met les pieds
à l'étranger on a la conscience on a la
pleine conscience de la chance que l'on
a
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des de
cette enfance entre 0 et 10 ans de ce
monde qui nous entoure lorsqu'on est
petit les parents qui nous disent soit
fort je ne dise pas comme ça mais il ya
toujours cette idée d'être parfait soit
parfait soit fort fait les choses pour
faire plaisir à maman
du coup le filtre notre perception de la
réalité se modifie plus on avance dans
l'âge plus des croyances des peurs des
angoisses viennent enlever de la pureté
à notre filtre personnel du coup la
réalité le monde dans lequel on vit
n'est plus n'est plus le même du coup
accéder au bonheur devient presque
difficile j'ai une personne lors d'une
conférence qui m'a dit je maxime elle me
posait des questions je disais que
j'étais en train d'écrire mon deuxième
livre et elle me dit maxime moi j'ai
écrit un livre mais je suis pas encore
prête
mais ça fait déjà cinq ans que j'écris
je dis pourquoi tu n'es pas encore prête
elle me dit il manque encore des choses
j'ai besoin de fignoler très bien je me
demande qu'est-ce que tu dois fignoler
eh bien ce n'est pas que je dois finir
les des choses mais il ya des petites
choses qui ne sont pas encore parfaites
il ya quelques imperfections
je lui dis effectivement c'est ses
imperfections qu'on aime c'est ses
imperfections qu'on recherche le lecteur
ne veut pas de choses lice
il veut la vérité l'authenticité nom
maxime je suis pas encore prête et bien
cette personne
j'ai peur qu'elle ne soit jamais prête
gl a créé son propre scénario d'échec
elle vit en fait avec une épée de
damoclès sur la tête sans le savoir
c'est à dire qu'en fait elle s'est
interdit de réussir quoi elle s'est dit
moi je réussirais pas son inconscient
dis tu n'as pas le droit de réussir tu
ne pourras pas écrire ton livre il
restera toujours à la maison
dans le petit tiroir à gauche près de la
commode et bien des scénarios comme ça
on en vit au quotidien
avant même d'avoir démarré quelque chose
on s'auto sa botte
on se sent pêche de se donner une chance
de réussir alors qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour y aller mais non il manque 6
ou alors il faut que ce soit très fort
ou alors il faut de toute façon ça ne
marchera jamais je vais le faire parce
qu'il faut que je te fasse plaisir de
voir en mai mais je vois là quand ça
marchera pas eh bien tous ces scénarios
que je vous décris ce sont ceux qui nous
on sait ce qui nous empêche d'avancer
ça vient tronqué le filtre de la réalité
de notre réalité et donc notre
perception est tronquée je vous invite à
prendre ce filtre et à le mettre à la
poubelle comme ça c'est réglé
on lui dit adieu et on retrouve de la
pureté
c'est pas facile à faire croyez moi
c'est un travail quotidien
mais je vous invite à chaque moment où
vous avez cette petite voix comme une
sorte de diablotins qui viendraient
derrière mon épaule me dire de façon tu
vas être planté a pas marché à prendre
le diablotin et à le dégager
visualisez le et retirer le de votre
épaule ne le laissez pas vous emmener
vers la spirale de l'échec
voyageons un petit peu dans notre
cerveau regardons les deux hémisphères
on a la partie gauche de la partie
droite
la partie droite est une partie
extraordinaire plus que c'est la place
de l'imagination
c'est l'endroit dans lequel on peut
créer imaginer visualiser lorsque je
rencontre des clients et qui me parlent
de leurs objectifs il arrive des fois
qu'ils me parlent de leurs vacances
d'été
ou est-ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est réfléchir à dans cinq ans ou est
ce que vous voulez être dans cinq ans
dans dix ans en quinze ans pourquoi ne
pas prendre cinq minutes de notre temps
dix minutes 20 minutes voire une journée
mm pour réfléchir à ce que l'on
souhaiterait avoir dans le futur
ce cerveau droit est magnifique pour
visualiser sept exercices de
visualisation m'a permis de construire
des choses avant même de les avoir
construit mon premier livre je les écris
avant même de qu'ils soient publiés
visualiser précisément en détail
l'endroit dans lequel vous voulez vivre
la maison
est ce qu'il ya une forêt derrière
qu'est ce que vous allez faire les
week-ends pour vous détendre
les gens voulaient fréquenté visualiser
cet environnement plus vous le
visualiserez plus vous aurez l'énergie
chaque jour tendre vers la réussite de
cet objectif le cerveau gauche est tout
aussi important les deux ont
véritablement une importance capitale
80 % des gens utilisent leur cerveau
gauche
seuls 20 % utilisent le cerveau droit le
cerveau gauche est exceptionnel pour
répéter les choses enregistrer les
informations analyser les choses
ce qu'on appelle la pensée factuel
ce cerveau gauche est exceptionnel une
fois que l'objectif est déterminé dans
cinq ans comment l'atteindre
si c'était facile tout le monde
l'attendrait l'acte de répétition notre
capacité à répéter un geste à travailler
à se former va être décisif dans la
réussite de notre projet c'est notre
cerveau gauche qui va le guider
salvator dali a mis 50 ans pour pouvoir
peindre un tableau en moins de cinq
minutes
la plupart des grands artistes chanteurs
danseurs acteurs n'ont cessé de répéter
des gestes au quotidien ont cessé de se
former de progresser avec humilité pour
atteindre un niveau de perfection de
simplicité
le plus dur c'est la simplicité quand ça
paraît simple en général c'est que c'est
il ya des heures de travail derrière
donc la complémentarité entre les deux
cerveaux est décisive
je vous invite vraiment à bien prendre
le temps de faire la partie
visualisation cas on utilise peu cette
technique qui nous permette de
d'imaginer notre vie de l'avoir de voir
le résultat accompli le sentiment de
bien-être que ça peut nous procurer et
c'est la source numéro 1 de motivation
sans motivation sans plaisir très
difficile la motivation et le plaisir
sont vraiment des choses qui sont
décisives pour la réussite de tout
projet de tout changement de vie
peu importe ce que vous faites en termes
de quantité un pas par jour suffit une
action par jour suffit tant qu'elle tend
vers l'objectif final j'ai envie de
conclure avec cette phrase de la au
dessous d'un philosophe chinois penseur
chinois qui a dit cette phrase un voyage
de mille lieues commence toujours par un
premier pas merci
[Applaudissements]